هل شعرت يوما برغبه التسلق الى بركان
والنزول داخل حفرته جورج كورونيس مغامر
يقول لا يمكنك الاقتراب من هذه الحمم دون
ان تسبح فيها هذا هو جورج كورونيس في بدله
مقاومه للحراره مع شريكه المغامر سام كوسم
وهنا يظهر جورج في اسفل حفره البركان في
جنوب المحيط
الهادئ لقد نزل الى عمق 12 قدم عمق يقارب
ارتفاع مبنى امباير ستيت واستغرق الامر
ساعتين لنزوله الى حوالي 50 قدما فقط فوق
الحمم ورغم ارتدائهما بدله مقاومه للحراره
فانه لم يمكنهما الوقوف بالقرب من الحمم
الا لبضع دقائق استخدموا ميزان حراره
بالليزر لقياس درجه حراره الصخور
المتطايره ويقول جورج ان بعض الصخور قد
تطايرت عليه وتسببت في ذوبان
البدله ويضيف ان الاصوات تشبه اصوات الرعد
او غساله الشيطان ويقول جورج انه من غير
المرجح ان ينفجر البركان وقد كان قلقين
عند حافه الحفره الضعيفه والصخور
المتطايره وجورج لم يكتفي بالنزول الى
البراكين بل تزوج على احدها عام
26 وقد تكون زوجته ميشيل اذابت قلبه ولكن
بركان مارم هذا اذاب كاميرته عندما وضعها
على الصخره واما جورج فلن يتخلى عن
الاقتراب من هذه الحمم البرتقاليه اللون
الرائعه ولم يكتفي باخذ صوره سيلفي بطبيعه
الحال بل لبس هذا
القناع